hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna work on something that I think is
really cool we're going to make our
search function a lot better because
we're gonna use algo Leah and I'll
explain what that is but we're gonna use
algo Leah to handle all our our search I
like getting all the data that going
through it all and providing the results
and we're just going to display it with
react so that's the plan for today first
of all I just want to say thank you to
everybody yesterday who provided some
encouragement and support to me on
Twitter and Instagram so as many of you
know I launched this project last week
the one that we've been working on for
so long and so I got a lot of positive
feedback but I did get some negative
feedback and some of it was was very
constructive and good and I'm okay with
that
but some of it was a little bit more
mean-spirited I guess and didn't really
even contain anything constructive so
that was kind of getting me down and I
think I just been stressed cuz I've been
working a lot a lot more than than usual
I wasn't feeling well my even though
I've I have been trying to exercise
regularly I think my immune system was
just wearing down so all these factors
just combined at the point of yesterday
morning I was just feeling down and it
just was like you know little bugs in
the site kept coming and I kept getting
comments from people through email and
social media things that you know
negative feedback and so I knew like you
know I just I know how I am and with my
history of depression I knew I got to do
something
or else I'm gonna get really depressed
here I'm not gonna be able to function
so that's why I I reached out to you all
on social media and just I'm just you
all responded just overwhelmingly and I
thank you thank you I really appreciate
it and it definitely helped it helped me
to feel a lot better I mean some of the
messages are just amazing and there were
some people I had no idea that some
people even knew who I was or watched
the show or that I impacted them at all
and it was awesome then to hear that so
I don't want to spend too much time and
not do any coding but I just I had to
say thank you to you all because that it
really meant a lot to me and I'm gonna
be going back and looking at those
messages probably many times to you know
just give me some motivation and help me
you know stay focused on you know just
trying to do the best I can so anyway
let's see we have a lot of people here
so I'm sure there's new people
let me explain briefly what's going on
here I'm a front-end developer and
employed full-time at a small university
and this is me doing my everyday work
I'm in my office right now
I'm about to work on a project the main
website for this university that we just
launched last week and so this is not a
tutorial but I do my best to try to
explain what I'm doing and I'm welcome
to any questions that you have just let
me know I'll take breaks periodically
and answer questions at the end if there
are any questions left I'll answer all
your questions so hopefully you can
still learn something for me or from the
other people in the chat even though
right it's we're kind of going in the
middle of the project right we've been
working on this project for a really
long time this is video 98 so yeah so
that's what we're gonna do I'm gonna set
a timer here in just a minute and we're
gonna start with the code
I'm gonna kind of ignore the chat for a
little bit while I code and then I'll
come back to the chat and catch up on
things so let me just really briefly
just check out who's in the chat now and
say hello hey I see a lot of you you're
saying hi how's it going I see there are
some questions there are a few questions
about why I'm using algo Lea over
elasticsearch so let me address this
since it's definitely going to deal
directly with what we're doing
I've tell you the truth I'm really
impressed with algo Lea and yesterday I
already put a bunch of data in there so
I like what I see so I'm open to
elasticsearch maybe in the future if I
learn more about it and figure out
that's a better way to go I'm definitely
open to it but for now this is a feature
that I really want to get live as soon
as possible I'm not satisfied at all
with the search that I created before it
worked well for some of our previous
projects because there was a small
amount of data but with such a large
amount of data with this site it just
does not work there's there's too much
if there's too much data for a user to
be able to find what they're looking for
your the search we did before was just
very simple if that word existed in that
particular post it would show up well
we're talking about thousands of posts
here so a users not going to be able to
scroll through all those so this is
gonna help and and you'll see I'll show
you what we can do with this data in a
little while so if you're still confused
about what a goalie is or what it's
going to do just stick around
you know you'll see it in action okay so
any of the other questions in there
right now I'm gonna get to those after
we do our first coding session so let me
switch my screens here you can see this
is the site this morning I added a
feature where
different images would show up so it's
kind of just a random as to what image
shows up just a simple you know math
math dot random and in JavaScript and I
just put all the images in an array and
so it just does a random that grabs a
URL from the array and puts it in as the
background image so if you click you get
different images sometimes you click and
it's the same one obviously because it's
random so just have some different I had
some feedback on the images and they say
to be nice to get images from different
parts of campus and about different
things going on I did I definitely I got
the most vocal feedback and this
actually came from some students were
where actually they said well you know
we're a Catholic college but it doesn't
really say anything about us being
Catholic on the main page except for
this little thing right here and that
was actually true it was kind of not
really my intention to do that I just
kind of wanted to highlight all of our
degrees because I wanted people to know
we have really good academics here and
from our research that showed that that
was an area that we could improve on in
terms of the public's opinion of our
university but I threw some pictures in
there see this is our original picture
and actually from what I heard these two
women saw this this picture and we're
sharing it on social media and we're
excited that they got on the website so
I actually don't know who they are I
just this picture I thought was really
great to put on here it shows women in
stem and they just looked really joyful
in the picture so I thought this would
be a good picture to use but I'm glad
that they liked it so anyway let's uh
let's get started let me go try to find
my timer I'm all let's see
okay that's better I'm gonna start up my
server let me make this bigger let's
start up our dev server I did a get pool
this morning so we're all up to date
I've been working a lot from home so I
had a ton of changes lately up III it
seems like I'm busier now after the site
launch than I was before the site
launched we ended up finding a lot of
broken links because there were multiple
URLs for each page that I didn't really
know about so that was that was a little
bit crazy so I think we found almost all
the broken links I mean I'm sure we'll
find some more but I'm trying to get
some consistency and only having one URL
go to one pace and not have all this
stuff everywhere okay so we got a dev
server's running now I'll be able to
start up and grow I'm gonna copy and
paste a link in the live chat right now
and that's gonna let you all check out
the changes we're making to the website
in real time and you'll be able to
inspect it and everything right there on
your machine so I guess I'll go over
here and this is the live site this is
at Franciscan ddu you check that out if
you want but I'm gonna go to localhost
right now and I'm gonna put this on a
different branch let me make this a bit
bigger I think that's probably still too
small okay so down here in my terminal
and I'm using Visual Studio code I know
usually people ask about this and I just
have the little terminal option down
there so if you go to view you can open
your terminal right there and I always
have to open one to run the dev server
and the other one for commands usually
like gate commands but I'm going to go
to a different branch right now and if
you're not familiar with git it's
basically like I can test out some
things like a separate version of my
project without messing up my main
version that that I'm going to push to
my live server at some point so this
will let us work without having to worry
about breaking something because if we
do we can always switch back to the
master branch make a quick change if we
need to all right so that's that's what
I'm going to make this branch so I'm
gonna do a git checkout with a be flag
that'd be flag is what's going to make
the branch check out it's actually going
to switch us to the branch so we're
combining two git commands and then
after that I just type the name of the
branch so this is going to be let's just
call it search hopefully hopefully I
don't have a branch called search all
right nice I thought I might so we have
a new branch called search and now what
I'd like to do is I'm gonna use a
package from algo Leah called react
instant search so I'm just gonna copy
and paste what they have in their
instructions and get so that's yarn add
react instance on and then I'll go lea a
bully a search so while that's loading
up I'm gonna paste macapá and paste into
the live chat the link to this
repository is that okay so if you want
to check out this this package there's
the link right there also let me give
you a link to the documentation so you
can check that out as well but second
link is the documentation and then we'll
go I'll show you the algo Lea dashboard
and what's going on over the
in just a minute all right so all of
this is now loaded and I'm gonna try to
do just something really basic first to
make sure everything works
we're definitely I'm gonna have to set
up some API keys before it will work
with the data that I brought in so let's
get that running and I need to I'm just
gonna copy and paste the basic getting
started code so you'll see it in a
second when I paste it in here and let's
see let's just do this on the search
page so we already have a search page
but what I'd like to do here is I guess
add this search in hmm let's get rid of
you know let's not get rid of anything
for right now let's just add this in and
then we know we'll probably end up
getting rid of most of this but for now
I just want a page where we can view
what's happening so right here in this
grid where we have our original search
whoa and I tried to copy everything in
there and that was that was a bad move
okay let me do this a better way okay so
I'm just gonna copy this component into
in here oops and I don't even need this
okay so we have this instant search
component and we're gonna pass in the
index name and the search client so I
don't have an index called BestBuy I'm
gonna have to figure out where my index
I do believe I have an index called
faculty or something like that let's see
yeah WP post
faculty so let's use that okay so I'm
gonna this in the index contains all of
the data we have on faculty so all of
our faculty profiles this one's kind of
cool because we should also be able to
pull images since we have featured
images so hopefully we can get that
working and then our search results will
contain little thumbnail images as well
which is kind of it looks kind of cool
looks fancy right now our search client
we need to pass in some data for that
and I'm gonna need to probably put that
in a dot end file so I don't put all of
my API keys out there let me see what I
need I may need search clinics cuz I
think the components your app
all right if you're following along let
me you know what let me bring some of
this over so you can see what I'm
looking at
so here's oops
am I looking okay here we go so here's
the documentation and then this is the
readme for the get update so I'm right
here I've just been copying pasting some
of this over
let me grab this while I'm here and I
while I remember we'll just pop this
down here okay and then we need to do we
need to bring this in and we can put
this I guess wherever let's just put it
right here it'll be easier or less less
scrolling around so I'm not sure what
values need to be here so that's what we
need to look up so let's just check here
and the documentation see if we can find
it
okay it looks like this one is it's a
little bit different
huh
all right let me know if you all are
seeing what I'm seeing here it looks
like the instructions are different here
and here I wonder let's see when the
last time the readme was updated readme
was updated a month ago so I'd say
that's that's pretty new we're looking
at I don't know what version this is I'm
gonna check the chat see just to see if
if you all notice something API ID and
key okay Harshit from the live chat is
saying the one on github is old is that
use the docs okay cool okay and Michael
crew is saying the app ID is latency the
API key and the index name okay cool
so actually this shouldn't be a problem
for me to put this in here because it's
not my secret API key right so I'll go
Lea can be used client-side so like it
should be fine
in terms of your API will be fine right
nobody's gonna get access to be able to
change anything on your API they maybe
could pull data from your API which in
my opinion is fine right because this is
all information we want the public to
have so why not give it to them all
right so let's do that let me go to on
my other screen I am going to go to my
dashboard just to grab my API keys
actually yeah let me show you the
dashboard because the the secret API key
is it's hidden right so nobody can see
that anyway so I'm okay with that
so this is the algo Lea dashboard we've
gone to API keys and
this is our application ID I'm gonna
copy that and let's put it actually
let's let's go with what the doc said
hmm actually the Doc's don't even have
me using algo Leah search so maybe I
don't need that all right so let's let's
go with what they say here let's get rid
of this and get rid of this and scroll
down there we go
okay so we're not gonna have search
client I'm gonna paste this we already
have a next name so let's get rid of
that now we can throw in our app ID oops
our app ID and our API key okay
let's save that and let's see Oh harsh
it says it's feeling too sleepy today
see our [ __ ] I know it's really late
where you're at thank you so much for
for joining us and for helping out okay
so hopefully everything else is ok I
know I kind of switched instructions
there in the middle we could probably
get rid of I'm not gonna do it right now
we can clean it up later but we may not
need that
I'll go Leah search package that I
loaded so maybe I'll get rid of that in
a little bit but first let's just see if
if this is working let's see all right
so this is use widgets here which it
looks like we've already put in yeah we
put in a search box and it hits so let's
see if anything shows up you all may
already know you may be going to that
page already so I'm gonna go to search
and see
hmm nothing showing up here yes so it
looks like nothing is rendering let me I
want to inspect this and just see if if
anything is there see what's going on
respect
oh it's popping up on my other screen
let's see so it should be
yeah that's weird all right let's
instance search box
mr. Shido alright let's go back to the
documentation feel like I can't talk
today I keep like searching for the
words I'm pretty tired I was up before 5
a.m. today it's that it was actually
exciting so there's a conference in
Russia a JavaScript conference called
holy J s and it's held I think twice a
year once in Moscow and once I can't
remember the other location but I got I
guess kind of interviewed to be a
speaker at the one in Moscow at the end
of November so I had to do the interview
at a time that was convenient in Moscow
time so it was 1:00 p.m. in Moscow when
I did the interview but it was 6 a.m.
where I'm at so I wanted to make sure I
got up early and was prepared so I may
be speaking about how we built this app
at a conference in Russia in November I
really hope I get to go I've never been
out of the country
oh I am gonna go to Germany though for
the for the duck fest conference so
that'll be cool so I may go from being
30 I'll be 33 in October so I'll go from
being 33 years old and never leaving the
country to go on to two foreign
countries in November maybe that'll be
fun all right let's see what our widgets
are okay so search box that's good we
did that right search box okay and then
all right let's see about styling the
widgets maybe
I know I mean it just it seems like I
should see something without the styling
right anything hmm maybe I'll I'm gonna
get rid of hits cuz I don't really know
what that does right now and I'd rather
keep it simple just you know if we're
just trying to make this work so let's
get rid of that and let's also get rid
of see I don't want to try to I don't
want to get rid of too much and then
have let's just move this somewhere my
fear is that I start removing this stuff
and then it causes errors and then I
have to try to go back and see you we're
gonna take up half the stream just
removing things so let's see let's just
throw something in here put a little
further down the page maybe we'll have
better luck if it's showing up yay look
we got something so right here we have a
search whoops I accidentally clicked on
a link okay so we have a search here
let's see what happens let's see if we
can find some education faculty members
search
okay nothing happened
I'm gonna check the console I have it
open another screen and it looks like
we're getting an error
all right let me show you the air we're
getting
okay
no it's not yeah let me make this bigger
okay okay so it failed
that's your failed loading post so it
looks like it was trying to get
something and failed and we got some
errors here which ten truths I'm not a
hundred percent sure this is just from
ago Leah I I suspect it is but I'm
trying to see I don't see anything that
says for sure that it's coming from
there so I guess we'll try
so it's trying to make a coal
see what's happening here's all our al
Golia queries and we can see let's make
this large we can kind of see what's
happening here's the results that we get
from the index post faculty and it looks
like yeah we're getting we're getting
data right so we have here dr. Alex
Plato I just saw him earlier today he's
a good guy he's also a philosophy
professor and he has the best name for
philosophy professor okay so we actually
did get the data I'm just not exactly
sure why what happened here okay so we
got the data it's just not displayed
let's look at our console again so it
failed no that's not it
there we go okay so it looks like it
failed up here but it actually worked
down here so maybe let's just get rid of
everything restart it and then see
what's happening if I can find there we
go okay let's just try it again with
search again let me refresh and then
we'll do search all right actually let
me check first okay
looks like we're getting whatever errors
we just got before may not even be due
to algo Leah
we're gonna search again and see what
happens
interesting okay so it seems like we
fail first and then it works but in any
case nothing is actually being displayed
so let's go back to our documentation in
about three minutes I'm gonna go back
and answer some things in the live chat
Harshit says you need hits component to
display data thanks oh [ __ ] I guess that
component I just deleted was more
important than I thought so let's throw
that back in there and we'll put it down
under the search box the hits component
and we'll go up here and make sure we
import hits component Harshit I thought
you're going to sleep but you came back
to save the day thank you okay
oops let's Hey look at this we we have
it it looks not great but we have it
cool so the data's here
look it's a live search so I just typed
biology let me zoom in this is so I just
typed in biology and we get the the data
I don't know see if we have anybody
named Joe no no Joe Joe is there we go
we do have some joseph´s though that
that works cool all right so next step
then we need to make this look good we
it's working obviously so that's
important right it it's it's on the site
we're getting the data it works here's
the next steps because the timer's about
to go off so I'm going to do these next
steps just so we know where to pick off
not only do we need to make it look good
which is definitely important but we've
only searched for faculty right I have a
lot of other things that want to search
for so right now every post type is an
individual index in algo Lea so we need
to figure out how do you search multiple
indices with algo Lea Michael says
that's fast yeah it's insanely fast it's
so much faster than what we built so
it's definitely it's better in many ways
so we need to try the first thing we
should do is make sure you have all the
data in order so let's figure out how to
search for multiple indices then once we
see what all the data is going to be
like then we can figure out how we're
going to display it first thing we'll do
though is before we try to make our own
solution we'll see what solution comes
prepackaged with I'll go Lea I think
that styling section that I skipped over
is probably gonna come in handy here so
that's what I look for if we like how
I'll go Lea styles it then maybe we'll
do it like that hopefully maybe it'll
work right off the bat maybe some
minimal styling changes and then we can
have this thing live like before I leave
today which would be awesome okay short
break I'm gonna go to the live chat I'm
scrolling all the way up to the top I
may answer as many questions as I can
let's see just a lot of people saying
hello so I'm not gonna read out all the
individual lows but I am reading them so
I know that you said I and I'm saying hi
back Morrow says
if possible use test-driven development
I know I know
I need to be better with using tests and
I'm just always busy and I don't make it
a priority
realistically I mean that's that's the
truth if if I made it a priority I would
probably do it but it's so tempting to
just you know get code written without
wearing about tests so I need to do a
better job at that and feel free to call
me out on that if you all see me doing
it too maybe I ought to take a course on
test writing tests and part of the
reason why I don't do it is because I
just don't feel confident my skills at
it so that might be a good idea route
Carmen Carmen says you're doing an
amazing job don't listen to the negative
feedback thank you I appreciate that I
appreciate it I mean I sometimes there's
some truth in the negative feedback so
I'm just I'm trying to I'm trying to
read it hear it you know and see like
what what is the truth to it so like
some of the feedback about not actually
showing any not giving any indication
that this is a Catholic University you
know the way that people were saying it
was kind of mean but the truth was yeah
actually I mean the previous website it
was really obvious in this website it
wasn't so the truth was hey maybe I
ought to include some type of image that
would show that so I mean it is truth
but it you know when you get so much of
that it does just kind of wear you down
like even if I'm trying to ignore it you
know it still gets it's in there you
know it's in your brain orhan says in a
word I can't say to the haters
no worries you're doing a majestic job
oh I love that a majestic job thank you
appreciate that Morrow says I'll go Leah
uses elasticsearch in the background it
just makes it easier in influent Oh
awesome
that's really cool I did not realize
that
yura says you're looking bad don't take
it so close to your heart oh well thank
you I appreciate the sentiment uh-huh it
stinks that I'm looking bad but like
realistically my my eyes were probably
red like I'm I was up super early let's
see
Morrow says algo leah is better for just
front-end devs if you're full stack you
can use elasticsearch so you have more
control over the search okay good to
know good to know I guess it may be I'll
check it out at some point and use it on
a future project we're working into this
project it seems like something maybe
I'd need to research a little bit more
to get right the trip says do you enjoy
your job not are you happy with it but
do you enjoy it I I really I do enjoy my
job I mean there are all these parts of
a job that you don't enjoy so sometimes
like the the attitude of people that I
work with
not necessarily in my own Department but
like in the the larger organization is
frustrating so I don't necessarily enjoy
that part of my job but I do enjoy what
I do I enjoy building websites apps
making them look nice - making them fast
and through that helping people to get
information or do their jobs you know
better than they did before I mean I
think that's really cool
that's that's pretty awesome so I
definitely enjoy that trip says as much
as you did when you started coding
honestly I think I enjoy what I do now
more than I did when I started because
I'm better at it now before there was
just so much I had to think about
everything everything was hard right
there was so much that I didn't know and
so much that I was like I don't know if
I can do that now I know I'm more
confident in the things that I know and
I'm okay with the things that I don't
know
right I realized that I can't be an
expert at everything so I've just been
able to let go and not worry that I'm
not an expert at everything and just say
you know what like I'm gonna do what I
know how to do I'm gonna try to learn as
much as I can but at the end of the day
like I'm gonna try to produce something
awesome you know no matter what
technology end up using or whatever like
so I like that I don't know I I think it
can be like that with everything when
you first start something it's it's fun
because it's new right but then you get
into this area where like you start to
realize how bad you are at it because
you're new and then it's not as funny
cuz you see other people doing awesome
stuff and you can't do that yet
so once you get past that and I think
I'm I'm past that to a certain extent
right there's still a ton of cool stuff
I want to be able to do but I can't yet
but I can do a lot so now it's it's fun
you know I know okay if somebody asked
me to do this thing I know I got this
right now it's not a matter of can I do
it it's well like how am I gonna do it
how fast can I make it how nice can I
make it look what new tech can I use and
learn while I'm doing this and that's
just that's fun it's fun for me in the
added thing of being able to see you all
on the livestream
it's just this whole nother level of
just coolness to the to what I do that
was it's just unexpected and really
amazing so that's a really good question
I made me think but I I like that I like
that question okay definitely didn't get
through all the questions I'm gonna
start up up on with our timer again and
let's see cool harsh it just gave me the
elbow Leah CSS awesome so let's go over
and throw the CSS in our
head there we go so we have our layout
here and let's grab so Harsha put in
that CSS I want to just you know what
I'm just don't feel like actually typing
out a link tag so I'm gonna grab this
let's see I think this is what our
should this instance there's things
oh that maybe this is different
actually this is different I wonder
I'm gonna grab these because they're
already there reset you cook this
alright we'll try the reset one first
what is the difference okay all right
let's see if they recommend using the
reset so let me grab this one and we'll
paste this in so we have this little
head component and that lets us throw in
things like link tags right so we
already have this link tag of our page
CSS and which page dot CSS gets used on
almost everything so might not be a bad
idea to just make that global I'd have
to make sure okay let's see what we have
now hmm
okay looks like maybe didn't do anything
where's my CSS okay that came in
why did not do anything reset is basic
elbow leah is more stylish okay
so let's go with the more stylish one
okay let's go back here and see let's
see what the Algol ei1 is where is my
oops gotta close that tag
whoops keep going the wrong way okay all
right
oh yeah that's definitely different here
okay cool so now we're getting us still
like we're getting a lot of a lot of
this so we probably need to say to
indicate somehow exactly what data we
want to display because a lot of this is
completely irrelevant but this is pretty
cool I mean this is not it's not exactly
the style that we use for the for the
website so I would be okay with adding
it like in here with this type of
styling temporarily just to get a good
search in there because the
functionality is important to get in
there right away but and then maybe
going back and redoing it so that it
matches our material design style but
this is good enough I think it could
work definitely need to figure out ah
you know what I just said at the LAT end
of the last Pomodoro session that we
were gonna get all our data before we
started styling and I completely forgot
okay well we reversed reverse that and
let's see
sorry my boss just sent me a question
[Music]
okay so up to this point it's been
mostly me entering data and some student
workers and I haven't gone through the
process yet of really teaching anybody
else how to enter data so it's a little
bit crazy for me because every time some
of these changed like I get these
questions so alright let's check our
documentation and figure out how to get
search multiple indices right is that
how you do it and it's not indexes right
its indices I don't know I think it's in
this thing
okay let's see if it says it
parameters
okay char-broil says sometimes it is
indexes all right let's go to the
dashboard and see what it says all right
emolia
uses the term indices so I guess we'll
just use indices for now all right here
we go multi index why didn't I see that
there we go you can use multiple index
components each index component takes
one prog okay
all right let's check out both examples
so it looks like this there's two
different ways to do it
[Music]
not that one
let's go to source and check out app
okay so they have Instant Search and
they have one index there and then
underneath hits they use index oh and
then results in the second database all
right let's just copy and paste this and
see how it looks see if this is what
kind of what we're going for
let's import index first and then we use
it down here whoops down here
so under hits
sorry I'd my boss mr. speak again so
let's put in a real index name let's go
to our dashboard and see faculty thought
I had more than this Oh
[Music]
we could go with
campus security cuz I think that's all
there's all have the data that they need
so we'll go with that so
and the Guru's
- Aiden okay
it's
okay all right so this will put them
they'll be displayed but they'll just be
displayed below interesting
okay
all right let's see we need I'm just not
sure about that I mean I
I just don't know about it it works but
I'm not I'm not sure that that's the
best thing
let's look at the other option so what
is this react instant search mmm multi
index
it seems a lot more complicated but
maybe it'll give us what we want Matt
touch this
my phone is stripping I'll catch you
later see ya thanks for watching
alright um I'm selling at 12 minutes
okay let's try to get this other example
working
we may need to put this yeah you know
what let's just grab this whole
component let's make a new component and
we'll do this or how about this let's
just get rid of this entire search page
and pop this in here and call it search
okay and react autosuggest
I guess I have to do this yarn and
alright so we're getting react
autosuggest and API keys I got to put my
API key and again it's so convenient
when I have that little button that
copies automatically I mean it seems
like something like I don't need this
you know but really it's so helpful and
what did we have
VP pose faculty and then
get this let's go with news cool let's
see
Caravelle react instant search
connectors
let's check out the package.json from
this example make sure you have
everything right though I'm react
instant search obviously just looks like
we have all the packages
Michael was shocked that I just deleted
everything all right why is this not
working
what the heck
it should be reserved reacts instant
search connectors
all right let's go back to the
documentation maybe you need to use the
autocomplete connectors let's see what
it says about this
let's see
all right let's copy and paste this and
just search for it it's he what comes up
okay when you wanted to square widget
using another library late material UI
hey cool I do want to what are
connectors how to use them
okay
when I
when I first installed this I installed
react instant surge dome and not react
instant search right let's check our
package.json
yep okay here's we need to do let's go
yarn I don't know what the command is
let's try to remove let's double check
and make sure I don't need this dumb
thing okay cool we removed it
alright also while we're at it let's
remove a goalie I searched the goalie
search
then we can install yarn or we could we
could do yarn what is it called instant
react instant search all right so that's
hardship mentioned earlier the for
whatever reason the instructions in the
readme were out of date so we started
with those instructions and then we
moved over to the other one this which
were newer unfortunately it was actually
different packages so hopefully now
things will work so let's go back and
see yay all right what got beautiful
this pages alright let's let's see what
you want to say see if we have Co
computer science nothing what is
happening
we inspect I can't see anything why is
this this [ __ ] yeah what is going on
can't read proper teach everyone to find
it looks like some weirdness is
happening finish loading opposed yeah I
would getting stuff right see we got
from you and we got these queries
results faculty yeah yeah we got who is
this
yeah dr. Christina Safranski she's a
very nice woman talked to her last week
alright so for whatever reason we're
having some issues getting this rendered
but it looks like it works though it's
just it's not so we're getting the data
and that works that's important let's
see where I've gone wrong hey maybe I'll
look at the error message that that's
like a good idea okay I'm thoughts I
cannot repair preach everyone define
autosuggest yes 41
it's just 77 all right let's check this
out 77 Otis yes okay you know what
probably one of these props I passed in
is not working right with the data that
we actually have all right so those are
good
nice let's see what these are doing its
value
the states are proud of a sort of
section index
all right my timer went off let's do
another break and I'm gonna scroll up
and try to figure out why I left off so
we can answer more questions and
probably do another Pomodoro session
after this figure out what's going on
just it feels like we're close you know
just have to sort out what's going on
there with all those props might not be
a bad idea just go to the documentation
and figure out what those props actually
do
Masoud says I want to learn computer
software coding system awesome well
hopefully you'll be able to learn
something from my my streams feel free
to ask any questions what's up dude says
hey you future bald guy
it said blad guy but I'm assuming bald
guy I hope I don't go bald but I mean it
could happen I'm I kind of like my hair
I did yes says hey you're doing a really
good great job please keep it up thank
you I appreciate it
Divya says today I had a react Redux
interview I was supposed to make an app
which renders data from their Bitcoin
API and it made me so confused because I
made a fetch data action with Axios get
requests oh well I mean what happened
did you end up being able to do it I
mean how did it go
mit plus this thank you for your awesome
informative answers you're welcome
thanks for watching
hard says are you gonna use react
instant surge yep
actually that was probably really early
on before I said I was gonna use it
let's see
Phoenix says today I successfully
created my blog site using Gatsby
it was previously playing HTML
Javascript it's a great tool made a few
mistakes they cost a couple of hours but
I learned oh that's awesome
congratulations
how many says amazing progress on the
website since last time I saw it great
work oh thank you I appreciate it
Albert asks would CSS library I'm using
it's called material UI mom would gave
me a little winking kissy face with a
heart emoji so thank you Carlos says hi
Jesse hello everyone good to be able to
watch alive again haven't been able to
watch live these days back awesome
well I'm glad that you are able to watch
live it's good to see you John says I
guess I missed a bunch at the point you
came in not too much I guess
Carlo says Jessie maybe you can come to
Switzerland would be great that would be
so awesome so alright so anybody that
may at some point everyone I like hang
out with me get a cup of coffee or
whatever if you're ever near Pittsburgh
let me know because I'm not that far
from Pittsburgh and I would drive up
there and hang out but if there's a tech
conference near you let me know like in
enough time that I can try to apply to
speak there and then I'll go or if it's
in the United States my employer would
may pay for me to go so that would also
be okay if it's outside the United
States I doubt they'll pay for me but if
I be if I was a speaker the conference
would probably pay for me to go and then
I'd be more than happy to come hang out
so I try to stay up to date on the
conferences but there's so many of them
it's just it's hard to keep track of all
of them and I really like going to
conferences and meeting people and
speaking
and see John says a nice opportunity to
think of me on your travels since you
share your birthday with me oh really
we share a birthday no way so my
birthday is October 29th so if anybody
has lots of money laying around and
wants to buy me something I'll send you
a link to my Amazon wishlist and no I'm
just I'm just messing around but if you
want to wish me happy birthday that'd be
cool see I mean you don't have to right
now but like in October
turbo asked if I've ever been to an
O'Reilly conference I have not but I'm
really interested in it they seem like
huge like cool conferences so definitely
would be be interested in going aren't
they they're they're kind of expensive I
can't I don't want to say for sure but I
like vaguely remember that those
conferences are a little bit more
expensive than the conference's I
usually go to okay my timer went off
again so
I'm gonna I'm just kind of scanning
through to see where the next question
is so I can start there next time
okay I'm gonna write down this question
or that timestamp
oh my goodness I just looked at my phone
I don't think I've ever had this many
notifications I wonder if you can see
that like that's all the notifications
across the bottom there that's so many
all right I don't know what's happening
it's lots of news stories and YouTube
notifications all right we're gonna do
one more Pomodoro session try to get
this working if I can't get it in one
more session then I'll just read the
rest of the questions and we'll end it
and I'll work on it later on hopefully
and I got until 5:00 so at 5:00 the
university is having this this like
Oktoberfest thing so we have a campus in
Austria and gommi
and so they call a calming fest but it's
basically gonna Oktoberfest thing and
that's at 5:00 and my kids are coming my
wife's coming so I got to finish by then
oops my boss just sent me this to show
me that the title hmm
okay so that is actually a big deal I
don't know if you can see cuz it's small
but there's no title tag on these pages
so that's important for search engine
optimization also there's no indicator
that of what this page actually is so
the URL you can see it's the theology
faculty but it'd be cool to have a title
on the page which is already on my list
anyway but it's it's gonna move higher
up on my list now that my boss said to
do it so I just told my boss that I'm
gonna finish the search thing first and
then I'll move on to that so I think
that that will be good let's see where
do we need off oh the props so we're
getting an error about okay so the error
happened let's see if we can get a
better surrender under suggestions all
right this guy wanted to check out that
error message see if we can get a hint
of exactly where it was rather
suggestion
it looks like it's the suggestions part
Chambord
[Music]
all right so let's read about this
render suggestion prop first and see if
we can figure it out where we add
autocomplete
that's the autocomplete component right
yeah let's see if we can find that
let's see
didn't come up when I search for that
connect autocomplete let's see there
it does not look like what I'm looking
for
all right let's see what this does
see
I just want
I just want to know what these crops do
right it's not
to actually name
all right so it seems like let me read
this error message again so it's trying
to trim a property that is undefined I'm
assuming then that it's that hit
property that's undefined so we're
passing in a string of name and a string
of mark so that should be fine it should
be defined the only thing that
potentially could be undefined is hit so
we're passing in render there's a render
suggestion
oh that's just a render suggestion
period good suggestions oh you know we
need to go up to suggestions fetch
suggestions clear requested just as a
value let's figure out where all this
stuff is getting passed around
okay so that's supposed to return
maybe maybe name isn't a value so I mean
hitch should work right but if it's
trying to get a name let's let's see our
data let's go back to our network and
see what we're getting so results and we
have hits right so each hit is going to
be here so we have hits and we have name
we don't right
no we don't have a name so what do we
want to use so this is supposed to be
good suggestion with value you know we
don't really want name we want I'm
assuming that name would be what's
actually displayed so let's see I guess
we want title post title so it one is
for this particular hits so it's gonna
go ahead it's in a particular head let's
see if we can just do a hit dot post
title and see if that'll work okay
it's kind of scanning through to see if
there's anything else that we might need
to change okay and there should be a
title what did I call that post yeah
there should be a post title for every
piece of data that we pull in since
we're dealing with with all posts I'm
gonna refresh this and let's go back to
the consoles here we're getting a new
idea
we're gonna go see we're getting okay
we're not getting that error anymore
that's good we're still not displaying
anything you're not displaying anything
so let's let's inspect just to see if if
it's just yeah yeah nothing's coming up
that's his post underscore title oh is
that it was it did I put the wrong thing
in good good catch on that let's double
check that it's it is post underscore
title awesome I'm so glad you saw the
who has that swag swag I caught that
post underscore title and that's
probably our issue I'm really glad you
caught that because it may have taken me
forever to figure it out alright let's
see if we get something now
no I me refresh manually just double
check and make sure okay it's still not
let's see if we're getting any errors
the okay no errors whoops not on console
I no errors which is good see if we
could do that yeah I was wondering if we
can make an error by typing in some
gibberish but still no errors so that's
good okay let's see render section title
let's check out where that's a render
render section title alright actually
that's not it we want not this section
what's a suggestion
hmm and let's say instead of the hit
let's let's see if we can get the title
to render here I'm not really sure what
yeah I'm there's gotta be some
documentation for this that I'm missing
that explains more about what but this
does fail prop type string supply to
highlight expected okay so it does
expect an object not a string so let's
bring it back down the head okay
oh okay that's a great idea
let's love this we're gonna console.log
hit just to see what we're getting and
that was dexter of worlds says love the
object great idea when all else fails
console.log to the rescue
I'm just I'm going to do that too just
to clear the console
I see we get whoa all right okay so this
is what we get when we get hits so it
should be hit dot and then this post
title would give us the title
okay
maybe wasn't the same name before
maybe it's looking for the attribute and
it's gonna highlight that a so maybe
what we need to do is say maybe it's
gonna use this value for the search well
it's worth the try we'll figure it out
in a second
yes that was it okay cool yeah who needs
documentation trial and error right all
right cool
so all right so that's that's what we
need basically it will show whatever we
put in here tag name I don't know what
this tag name thing is let's try to give
it another value
let's give it this post type value and
see what happens
oh wait so I don't know what that is
they didn't do anything visually let's
see if it did anything down here
oh post tight what's bio highlighted mom
it's supposed to be highlighted and it's
not interesting
let's see
this class is supposed to be
highlighting it but it looks like I
don't know maybe we're missing some
styles but I still can't find what
happened yeah I don't know what this tag
name is for but at least we know we can
get that displayed which is cool
okay the pulse is the name that you are
giving to tag name is becoming the tag
name
hello
okay
that's night
okay yeah so the the post type should be
campus security but if we search that's
not actually listed anywhere on the page
kept here but this is not it has extra
stuff there so that's not it so I'm not
exactly sure what this is doing right
now
hmm all right but this is this is good
this at least lets us know like what
it's working we can get the data back
and we can display the data on the page
right so this is good news and what
we'll be able to do then let's see the
data we have make sure we have the the
proper data okay so what we need is
okay so we definitely need the title and
content or as you say we don't we don't
necessarily need to show the content I
guess we just need to make sure that I
get searched if we have an image it'll
be cool to show the thumbnail image the
only piece of data that we're really
that we're missing that's very important
is we have a special field called
what's it called called search URL and
that was added with a wordpress plugin
called advanced custom fields I need to
create a plugin to be able to have our
boliya through the I'll go Lea web press
plugin be able to get the data that's in
advance custom fields so I can't
complete this until I do that so that's
definitely going to be I mean that's a
crucial step that has to be done
and it would also be good to find some
documentation for what what I can do
with this component this autocompletes
there is it autosuggest was i searching
for the wrong thing the whole time I was
where is autosuggest from
okay so this is why I couldn't find
documentation I think this is a
completely separate thing okay
there we go cool look at this we got all
the props right nice now we can see what
this is
all right so suggestion value
implemented to teach autosuggest what
should be the input value when
suggestion is click ok render suggestion
okay so in render suggestion we could do
whatever we want
alright so that's that's pretty cool
input props passed through arbitrary
props to the input must at least about
you know change it okay hold it
everything's just just in highlighted
with whatever to the highlighting
session she knows
alright there's all kind of cool stuff
I'm not gonna read through all this
right now on the stream they'll be
boring for you all but this is really
cool I'm gonna paste this in the live
chat and that way if you all want to
check that out you can but this seems
really cool like we could definitely do
a lot with it and customize see render
suggestion
mm-hmm okay so we're getting I wondered
where we were bringing in highlight
we're pulling in highlight from Instant
Search all right so if we want to know
what's going on with highlight we need
to look that up in the instant search
documentation there we go
we use the mark tag to highlight this
tag is specifically made for
highlighting pieces of text
the default tag is am mostly fellahin
okay so this is the actual HTML tag that
gets used then interesting let's see
what that looks at we should be able to
see that not now I don't know what I'm
looking for
yeah look at that so post it's literally
taking the word post type and putting it
there that makes sense now so we could
throw in mark and see what that looks
like okay now we can see the
highlighting is working that makes a lot
of sense
all right cool so highlight yes so this
just says what we want to highlight go
to custom hit widget customer would you
for the results
oh okay
interesting
so wonder if we could do something like
I wonder if this work you do this
so I started using a different keyboard
at home so my typing is like all over
the place I think because of this let's
see if we can get content to show up
here I want to see if I could put both
of them together if it'll work yes
check that out nice so oops I didn't
mean to click on that
nice let's just throw in a and ugly BR
new for second
what didn't work all right
anyway that's really cool so that's
awesome
all right anyway my timer went off so
for now I think I made a lot of good
progress not ready to go live with it
just yet
but it came really far it's it's nice so
let me go back to the chat right where I
left off at I may answer all your
questions okay first I need to take a
drink of this G fuel because I'm tired I
haven't said this in a while but if
anybody from G fuel is watching
I would definitely allow you to have the
honor of me sponsoring you just if you
give me some free G fuel I would shout
it out on the show
just a suggestion started out there or
if you're a rival company to G fuel I
would be interested in switching if I
could get free stuff that's caffeine in
it
all right I'm sorry I lost my place
I'm just strolling okay here's nothing
it's a question okay 12:35 mic
distracted by this atlantis Morissette
song that's playing right now my
headphones I had 90s music Clint says
how does it get all that data does it
send a get request so we're talking
about algo Leah does it send a get
request per letter you typed algo Leah
which does what amounts to magic and
then sends back a response
she
let's see what it does
we can go let's move the console back in
so we can see it at the same time what
is that
okay so we'll keep the console here and
[Music]
let's see what's happening yeah it looks
like we're getting data back on every on
every click we can look at the network
at the xhr request and see we go thanks
it's hard to see there's too many all
right I mean that's a lot of requests so
I'm well yeah I'm guessing on every
single time we tell you I have no idea
how it does it that fast but that's
that's pretty cool we can check our
dashboard and see I wonder if it'll tell
us like the activity 24 minutes
Wow yeah so in the last 20 the last 24
hours we have four hundred fifty-five
queries 90% of queries under 15
milliseconds wow that's cool
suit
okay so there's a conversation going on
a little side conversation about this
whole stem from birthdays and age and
kido and weight loss so it says I've
seen some and as you saying I've seen a
couple people do the snake keto diet and
drop a billion pounds quick I'm not a
huge cake fan but sweet coffee is my
weakness so I just brought that up
because I I did earlier in the year I
did like kind of a really strict diet
and I wasn't trying to do keto but it
ended up being kind of like a keto diet
and I did I lost like 15 pounds and it
it was like somewhat quickly so
definitely worked but I it's funny
because part of the thing that I did
have to give up was like putting a lot
of stuff in my coffee so I got in the
habit of just drinking black coffee
because it's you know almost no calories
so you just drink black coffee all day
caffeine's like kind of an appetite
suppressant and you feel kind of fool so
anyway just just reminded me I'm back on
a diet but it's way more relaxed at this
point
John Hanson says it is fast it's going
round-trip to Google where potatoes Oh
actually so we're not going around trips
so this may explain a little bit about
why this is fast so we have a round trip
not back to WordPress but what we've
done is we've exported as JSON all of
the data in WordPress and it's just sits
here in you know on algo Lea servers or
whatever so it just goes to there it
grabs that data and comes back so I
think that helps explain some of the
speed that it doesn't have to hit go
through WordPress through PHP into my
sequel and then back out which you know
that saves a lot of time
see
Nietzsche says front-end masters is free
right now can't follow any lessons
they're not savvy but I recommend to
check it out oh cool
all right so everybody front-end masters
is free right now so check it out
I can't I don't remember if I've ever
done one of their courses or not but
I've heard good things about them so if
you're looking for a course you know
definitely check out out mycosis earlier
we were talking about how I did get a
lot of complaints I don't know about a
lot but very intense complaints about
the new website not showing the
university as being really Catholic so
like here's the new site and Michael
says in the name Franciscan kind of a
giveaway than his Catholic yeah I mean I
I think there's a good argument to be
made that the the university already has
enough Catholic stuff associated with it
that we're not really at risk of losing
that just because we don't explicitly
talk about it on the home page like our
logo has a cross in it we do have the
name Franciscan right so I mean there's
there's something to be said for that
but it wasn't an unreasonable suggestion
that maybe we put something a little bit
more overtly Catholic you know on the
website so so that since I wasn't really
opposed to the idea you know I put it
there but I mean I think based on the
data that we have we do have a problem
with the the perception that our
academic programs aren't as good as
academic programs from other schools
yeah so I don't know that that's true
but that's the perception that we got
back from from some surveys and stuff so
that's what we want to try to showcase
what we do have so people realize what
that we have a lot of good stuff going
on here academically as well
charville says ask for a quick tutorial
on any rock I don't really know much
about n gger other than it works it's a
command-line tool you just start running
a server locally and then you put in you
just run a command basically saying n
grok here's where my server is port 3000
you hit enter and it gives you these
URLs and it does everything else so they
have free plans that are pretty limited
inconceivable who built and rock was
extremely generous and allows us to
basically have an unlimited free plan
for free code camp live streams
otherwise if you want to be able to have
a lot of users at the same time a lot of
people accessing your URL you do need to
have you know a paid plan I think it's a
monthly thing but that's pretty much it
I mean in terms of like setup and what
you need to do it's you're really easy
there's like a few steps to set it up
but once you do it like you're good it's
setup forever on that computer
I'm trying to find a question there's a
lot of like back-and-forth talk between
everybody in the live chat which is
awesome but if anybody's interested you
can read the the live chat when you're
watching this later on but I'm not going
to read it all out let's see
rythmic says what is the name of the
software or Visual Basic sorry if a song
we know it's um Visual Studio code I
think you're referring to the code
editor Visual Studio code Thanks that
Duchess says there's nothing wrong with
bald for guys anyway earlier somebody
said that I think they were trying to
say that I was going to go bald which
may be true and I said I didn't want to
go bald mad Duchess says there's nothing
wrong with boy well I thank you I
appreciate it I actually used to shave
my head it was especially nice like
during the summertime it's nice and cool
you can wear a hat you don't mess up
your hair like you're basically your
hair never gets messed up you don't have
any so it wouldn't be like completely
weird but I like the option of having
hair
Oh Nietzsche says Sonique I think
correct me if I'm wrong but I think
you're talking about this said you had
no idea at first what this number was in
the top until you saw it was a tell link
as did anybody else have that impression
is it obvious that this is a phone
number or not if it's not obvious what
can I do that would look nice that would
make it more obvious that this is a
phone number because I I mean I
obviously knew as a phone number cuz I
put it in there but I don't know how it
appears to other people so let me know
do you think this is obvious enough or
not if not what should I do
Julio says try this cool new extension
for live sessions via SlideShare in the
use code that's that is really awesome
I've heard of that I haven't had a
chance to use it yet but I would love to
to use it at some point Eva says you
should bind your class methods or use
arrow functions like methods of class
yeah I wonder at that point in the
stream I wonder if I'd already I was
copying and pasting a lot of code so
that may have been stuff I copy and
paste it in if not if it was stuff I had
already coded then let me know cuz I if
I can improve it I definitely want to so
anyway thank you for mentioning that Ava
let's see Dexter of world says are using
SAS or style components no we're using
what are we're using a variety of met
we're not using either one of those
we're using like plain CSS inline CSS I
don't even know what's it called CSS and
J s as that was called when we do the
CSS as a JavaScript object so we have a
variety of methods unfortunately I don't
have sass setup so but I normally do
preferred you sass I've used style
components a little bit before and
another project and I think I I think
they would be cool if I knew more about
them but I'm not comfortable enough with
them yet to really be good with them
Nikki says was that Atlantis Morissette
song called ironic it's like raining in
comprehensible gibberish no wasn't
ironic what was the one what's it called
let me check it was you ought to know
that was what is called it's actually
kind of like hardcore then of course
that was pretty hardcore back in the day
I was from the Jagged Little Pill album
John Hanson says I'm Don keto dropped 20
pounds awesome congratulations I said I
also do intermittent fasting no more
afternoon energy crash and better focus
than ever
workouts are much better - that's
awesome that's really cool
coda Lee says hi there hey how's it
going Carlos says having been a
university psychology professor for 11
years I don't think that overtly showing
that the University of Catholic is a is
a plus yeah that this university is a
little bit like so there's like a small
niche of universities that attract like
let's say like very devout Catholic
students and families so francisc
university is is one of those one of the
leading universities that does that so
the families that send their kids your
kids to come here like basically you're
looking for a place where they won't
feel like an outsider for being a devout
Catholic you know so it is kind of it is
a plus for what we for our target
audience so and that was what some of
the students and some of the professor's
were worried about was like are we
dropping that you know are we trying to
attract you know different students now
are we trying so I mean that really it
wasn't what we were doing at all in fact
we were just unfortunately what we had
and sometimes a student will really want
to come here you know because of the
reputation that this is a good place
where you can come you don't have to
worry about a lot of bad stuff going on
but they didn't feel like they get a
good academic education in whatever a
particular field they wanted to go into
so they went somewhere else
so our attempt the idea was okay well
let's let those students know that we
also have good academics right so Carlos
I think you're right for for a large
majority of people out there you know
they they would either care could care
less about the university being Catholic
or it might be a negative thing but like
I said we have a kind of a unique niche
that we're in right now Carlos says I
would go with what you had researched or
do a blind test show and click-through
rate with the Catholic symbol or without
it and see which gives you better
click-through rate for actually actually
I do
I really want to do some some tests on
different like different images and
different things we do and measure
click-through rates so that's going to
be something that I hope to get set up
soon so that we can really measure those
things so that when people come to me
with with ideas or criticisms or
complaints I can have this data to show
like you know I can see why you feel
that way but that's not really what's
happening you know and show them I mean
and also I'd like to know what works you
know maybe I'm mistaken maybe they're
right you know so I do really want to
have that data that's a great idea
oh okay
I had asked about the phone number and
several of you are saying put a phone
icon in front of it that is a great idea
that's a great idea I'm gonna add that
to my Trello board right now so I got
let me bring over my Trello board just
so y'all can see what I have going on
here in case you haven't seen it before
so like this is the Algol II a search
thing and we put it we just put in three
Pomodoro sessions so I'm going to up
this to 6:00 to say
that I've already done six sessions I
asked tomato to take five but actually
this card was just for research so I
guess I should do another card for
implementation but anyway the research
part only took me like one Pomodoro
session before I figured out I
definitely want to use this but let's
say add
okay and I'm gonna it says add phone
number add phone icon in front of a bar
phone number I'm gonna estimate that
that's going to take me 1 Pomodoro
session and then I am going to assign
that to myself there we go all right
okay
okay Nikki says I'm not familiar with
that format for the telephone number you
know what actually this is not really a
common format in the United States I
just like it for style reasons so I
think that's your you're not alone and
being unfamiliar with that format I
think a lot of people might be and I
just didn't I didn't even think about it
so normally there would be hyphens and
maybe even you know parentheses so I
think I like that the periods but I I
agree that's probably confusing so I
think I'm gonna go with the icon I'm
gonna keep the periods but I'm gonna go
with the phone icon that makes it really
obvious all right
sois this is Nikki that's how most
toll-free numbers look - the periods in
between yeah yeah I mean that's
yeah the periods are not not really
common I don't really know where I
picked that up from but I saw it on a
site before and I thought that looks
those kind of cool Jo Perez says what
are you doing well we're just kind of
finishing up doing some question and
answer
we did some coding earlier Morrow says
that okay so a lot of you say odd phone
icon I appreciate the feedback from you
oh I think that's a great idea
it looks like Gerald is not a fan of
Atlantis
Alanis Morissette so I'm telling her
early stuff I think is is pretty good I
I think it's better I'm not a huge fan
of her later stuff but she was really
edgy at first and it was I liked it
Nikki says the devout Catholic seeing
the site will immediately link
Franciscan with well Saint Francis so
it's not needed in my opinion but I get
the point
Nikki that is a great point like I like
I said I'm not gonna make a big deal
about it or argue because I mean at the
end of the day I want a code I want to
make things right
performing and look nice right so
content is not even exactly my thing and
unless it starts affecting performance
or like really messing up the look of
the site and then I want to get involved
but I I think you are right I think it's
an over reaction on the part of the
people that were saying it is that you
know the the people me right the people
who are devout Catholics will know
heaven that Franciscan University is a
Catholic school right and they will will
understand the reputation and there's a
ton of other information on the rest of
the website in our social media on our
YouTube that will definitely explain
that so yeah I think having I mean what
images do end up having like this one
right with the students praying right
images like that I think will help to
you know calm you know so people can
just calm down and realize like you know
we're not we're not trying to take away
anything so you know I think that'll be
good you know but at the same time it is
it is kind of odd to see that it's like
hey I'm looking for University so I can
get a degree so I can get a job and this
is your image here so it's just like you
know it's it's an interesting thing
right there there are several like
schools of thought here on campus about
like who we are as a university and I
think there's a good group of people
that realize that we're we're a mix of
different things right there's all kind
of reasons that people come here but
then there's some very opposite groups
that say like we need to focus on
academics right academics is the main
thing and there are other people say
like no we need to focus on on our faith
and like that's why people want to come
here and so yeah there's a huge
difference and then even within the
academics it's like some people are
saying well we we don't care about
making people job ready we're gonna
learn for the sake of learning you know
and there are other people are saying no
like we need we need to have programs
that will enable students to like
provide for their families and get jobs
and things so there's there's just a
whole
of discussion so you know it in
something as visible as the front page
of the main website becomes the focus of
discussion you know because everybody
sees it so anyway we actually did AB
data to show that students really
responded positively to like Ariel like
drone footage and stuff so let's go you
threw this in here Carla says you guys
need to do market research for those
things yeah that's the thing like we
have market research but number one like
it's just not not everybody has seen the
research right it's not like we publish
it everywhere although there's no reason
what we couldn't so not everybody's seen
the research and even when people do see
them see the research people want to
like think how they want to thank right
it's hard to convince them otherwise so
if they already have this opinion that
they hold strongly even when you show
them the research they like I'm up with
all these reasons why it doesn't matter
right so when I'm gonna make when I make
decisions I really try to fold the
research that way I always have that to
fall back on it's like this is not my
opinion or at least it's as little about
my opinion as I can make it and it's
more about the numbers it's more about
what we see from the research so when I
was doing redoing this page for the last
time I had a PDF of the market research
open at the same time and was looking at
it all and saying okay this is what we
want I also had like the most visited
pages on the website from analytics over
the past year up saying like this is
what people are clicking on so anyway so
I'm with you right there like Carlos um
I'm totally on board with that I think
that's the way we need to go we need to
get data on everything we need to
actually do things based on that data
that's not exactly what how things have
been done in the past here so it just
takes a while for people to switch over
and and learn to trust the data and not
you
their intuition about about things so
you know it's just gonna take oh not
everybody is gonna gonna change some
people were really excited about the
change and they're like yes finally
other people you know they resist it so
we'll see how it go so I mean my
department is pretty far ahead when it
comes to this kind of stuff
I've been here three years and since day
one I've been trying to get data and
make decisions based on data so we've
come a long way from where we were and
hopefully it'll get better but anyway
I'm getting far afield from actual
coding here anyway my department is
marketing by the way so I'm not like an
IT or anything like that I'm in
marketing so market research and as much
data as we can get from that from our
interrelate analytics is very important
to us let's see whoa Wow I've been
streaming for over two hours now
okay so it looks like I've gotten
through all the questions thank you all
so much for for watching and for all the
help there's definitely like several
times in the stream where I would have
been stuck and I you all y'all helped me
out so I appreciate you watching and
appreciate all the kind comments that
you all had today man on social media
and yeah don't forget to I'm active
mostly on Twitter and on Instagram but
you know check check it out it like if
you're interested I do put some content
up on on both of those platforms I also
have my own YouTube channel you can I
think there's a link in the description
this video I haven't done anything on
there for a while but I really would
like to have some tutorial videos and
things like that so if you if you like
what I'm doing here and you want to see
more of it you can check that out let's
see yeah I think that's it for me so
once again thank you so much and have a
great weekend should be back with
another stream on Monday